okay
hello again so here we are for another
episode
of uh q a about science and technology
for kids and others so we have a few
questions that were saved up here
let me take a look at these okay first
question on the list here was
what actually happens with my computer
when it crashes
that's an interesting question okay so
the the first
question is uh
when when a computer starts up
when you first power it on the computer
has to get ready to run the programs
that it will use to respond to you
so when a computer switched off
obviously it's not going to do anything
when the computer is
is switched on
for example when you click the mouse
when you press a key on your keyboard
the operating system of the computer
which is just a program
running in the in the in the in the cpu
of the computer
has to respond to what you did and
decide what to do
so for example a typical thing that
would happen is
you uh when you press a key on the
keyboard
the computer's operating system says
okay you pressed an f
key and then it has to figure out what's
it supposed to do
right now if you press an f key so to
get to that point
the way it works is okay
the the operating system decides uh
how to sort of operate the whole
computer and it decides
how to connect you to specific programs
so a program might be
i don't know uh some
a web browser for example or word
processor
or something like that the operating
system is responsible
for telling your computer when the key
when a key is pressed on the keyboard
that should be sent
to uh the word processor or when a key
is pressed on the keyboard that should
be sent to the web browser
um and what what's happening is so when
your computer starts up
so-called when the computer boots the
name
boots has a very strange uh
origin it comes from the idea of a
bootstrap
loader and um the there's a kind of a
funny tale i think it's a a german sort
of pseudo-folk tale of a certain baron
von munch house and if i remember
correctly
who uh i forget
was was um uh somehow he managed to pull
himself up by his bootstraps
which is kind of a thing that doesn't
make a lot of physical sense
because if you if you pull you can't you
can't make yourself go up i you know if
you're sinking in a pond or something by
by pulling on the your boot straps i
don't exactly know what a bootstrap is
i assume it's a strap that was used to
attach
leather boots or something um it doesn't
really work to do that but so it's kind
of a funny
a funny concept but this idea of a
bootstrap
loader for computers the idea was
when a computer is not running any
program it has to start running a
program
to be able to tell it how to start
running programs and that's kind of like
this pulling itself up by its bootstraps
idea
so when you first switch on a computer
the computer has to
start its operating system running and
its operating system
is then going to decide what programs to
start now some computers
um is not true with with windows or
macs but it is true with linux machines
for example
you can actually see the boot messages
and you'll see it
saying things like starting disk driver
starting this starting that starting the
other and it will be line after line
typically a few pages of so-called boot
messages
which say what the computer is doing
when it starts up
and the end result is the computer is
running this one master program the
operating system
and when you do things like type on the
keyboard
those events go to the operating system
the operating system
will then decide which program to send
them to now what tends to happen is
that the operating system if you if you
tell your computer run
three programs your computer
assuming it only has one cpu only only
one
uh one core to to actually run
computations and
the computer has to decide do you run
the first program the second program the
third program so
let's say you're trying to run three
different calculations
and some you're running some wolfram
language code or you're running
uh some uh some complicated
thing on your computer but you're
running three different versions
of of that the question is something has
to decide which version to actually run
then which version to run next which
version to one next because your
computer can only actually
it only has one core it can only run one
thing at a time
so there's usually a piece of the
operating system that's called the
scheduler
and the scheduler decides which program
to actually run
so for example if uh one of the programs
you're running is a movie player
it will typically say better keep the
movie player running
because otherwise the movie is going to
glitch so that will be a
well it'll be more or less a high
priority thing for the operating system
to run
if there's another thing which is let's
say
uh downloading a file and fetching
something it doesn't really matter if it
stops downloading
the file for 10 milliseconds because
it's running some other program during
that time
so that doesn't have to have such a high
priority in the scheduler
but so the basic idea is the scheduler
is deciding which program learns when
and as a human you pretty much won't
notice
unless the scheduler is kind of broken
in some way you won't notice what it's
doing because
the slices of time that it's deciding
run one program another program another
program is so short
that we don't notice it so it might be
10 milliseconds one millisecond
one thousandth of a second that kind of
that kind of time
now the one time when when we typically
do notice things
is when we tell the computer do
something where we say move the mouse
you better see the mouse pointer move on
the screen and it used to be the case on
an older computers and older operating
systems
that the program that was supposed to
move the mouse pointer on the screen
might have been swapped out might not be
running um
when when you actually move the mouse
and so you the mouse pointed you just
wouldn't see it move
and then then the operating system would
say okay right ready to run the program
that moves the mouse on the screen and
then you see the mouse jump to where it
was supposed to go
but so this process of figuring out
when you tell the computer to do
something like you click the mouse
it generates an interrupt and that
interrupt goes to the operating system
and it uh the operating system generates
an interrupt again i'm i don't know
quite how deep to go into this the the
the full story of how computer operating
systems work is kind of complicated
um there's usually a a central piece of
the operating system called the kernel
of the operating system and uh the um
these are usually uh sort of separate
programs that control
things like access to the keyboard
access to the mouse and so on
and those so-called device drivers
generate interrupts
when you click the mouse or something
they generate an interrupt to the kernel
the kernel will sort of wake up and say
okay what should i do now i just
had a mouse interrupt and it might say
well now i've got to go
send that to this program that deals
with moving the mouse pointer on the
screen
that's kind of roughly the way the way
things work
so when your computer is is running
smoothly the operating system is running
it's telling different programs to run
it's making sure that things get
scheduled properly all those kinds of
good things
now what can go wrong well uh
the operating system is has various
protections built into it
um that say if something goes
sufficiently badly wrong
you better just shut the computer down
so the worst case
that happens is an example of a bad case
that happens is what's called
kernel panic and kernel panic means
the kernel of the com of your computer's
operating system got really confused
somehow
something happened that you could
something it
there was some state of your computer
that your computer got into
that the kernel of the operating system
as far as its
programming is concerned your computer
is never supposed to get into that state
so it says oh my gosh i don't know what
to do it uh
has a kernel panic and it reboots your
computer
so it effectively is going to restart
the whole operating system as if you'd
switch the computer off and back on
again
um so that's one sort of reason that the
that a computer can crash is a
kernel panic um the uh generally
what what initiates things like that is
things like the following
issue so each program in your computer
has a certain uh piece of computer
memory that it's supposed to be dealing
with so let's say that you have a word
processor
it's going to represent the document
that you're that you're
processing in the word processor
somewhere in the memory of your computer
and uh the memory of a computer is so
okay different programs are all putting
their data into different places in the
memory of the computer
and roughly it's the responsibility of
the operating system to organize
where in memory all these programs get
to put their data
and your computer's memory will be laid
out and there actually are
addresses in memory and they just have
numerical addresses so it goes from
roughly it goes from kind of zero to
something in the
many billions if you have gigabytes of
memory in your computer
okay that's the that's the sort of
lowest level of representing of how
sort of data is put in the memory of a
computer in actual computers for the
last probably 30 years or so
there's been a concept of what's called
virtual memory and
virtual memory uh is something where the
addresses the positions in memory
are allocated on a per program basis so
while
your whole computer might have memory
locations going from zero to
10 billion or something any particular
program
will be as far as it's concerned it's
the operating system and i think of the
address translation unit
a lower level piece of the computer's
setup
is is making things so that as far as
the program is concerned it looks as if
it's running its very own
uh area of computer memory um that
just is goes from zero to whatever okay
so as far as the program is concerned
it's happily got this piece of memory
allocated and it's got a certain amount
of memory
maybe it has um uh you know a billion
memory locations allocated to it okay so
program's happily running along
okay now what if somebody has made a
mistake in the code for the program
because in low-level computer languages
you can say
things like uh put this
piece of data at this location in memory
at a location in memory with number 10
million 372 000
whatever you say put this data at that
location in memory
so let's say you do that but your
program says to put the data at a
location in memory
that wasn't part of the memory that was
allocated to that program
then what's going to happen well what
typically happens is
the program uh the operating system uh
causes the program to generate what's
usually called the segmentation fault
which means that it is trying to write
data
into a place that isn't the memory
allocated that program and so usually
that will
cause uh the program the operating
system will then make the program stop
running the program will crash
so similar things can happen with the
operating system
similar kinds of issues about trying to
write data
into parts of memory that where you
shouldn't be writing data for example
good example of that would be the kernel
of the operating net
system itself has a certain amount of
memory that it uses
to control the operations done by the
operating system like the scheduler for
example
and if somehow something is causing
uh things to be somehow through a
mistake of some kind
the the operating system something
writes
data into that piece of memory that was
supposed to be being used for
the kernel of the operating system the
kernel of the operating system will
freak out
and will basically generate for example
a kernel panic or something
and your computer will reboot itself so
when you run a computer for a long time
uh
things happen you know that there are
bugs and programs
that cause segmentation faults there are
uh bugs in let's say device drivers
where
data coming in from different uh network
ports or something they didn't quite
expect that this data would come in at
the same time as another piece of data
and that causes something bad to happen
and usually what happens if you're
running a computer
the operating system of a computer for
let's say weeks or months
um you know all these issues will kind
of build up all this kind of crud will
build up and eventually something will
go horribly wrong
and the computer will panic in some way
and it'll then go it'll end crash and
uh then uh and typically it'll reboot
itself
so that i don't think i've ever
explained how any of that stuff works i
can
i can go into a much greater level of
depth about all of that stuff i don't
think i've ever told anybody how many of
that stuff works it's
it's part of kind of the low-level um
operation of computers
um it's it's definitely fun to see um
uh the um if you if you can look at um
uh most operating systems uh somewhere
there's a file
that shows you the messages that were
generated during the the
the boot sequence for your computer and
that kind of gives you a um
a a view into what's really happening
inside your computer it'll say things
like
slash dev tty p1 and it'll say this is
coming to life that means uh
that's a device that is uh a keyboard
device for example that
is being its driver is being started by
the operating system
or there'll be a thing that says things
like a disc is being checked
um and so when when a computer comes up
often
it will run a a program that checks that
the data on the disk
is correctly configured so there wasn't
any uh because when the computer for
example if a computer crashed
it might have been in the middle of
writing data to a disk
and it might have partially written it
and partially not written it and that
would cause something
that would be a a messy thing in the in
the on on um
uh as as far as the the data that the
computer is stored so it tries to clean
that up
so anyway rough story of uh what happens
when a computer crashes
um
okay so there's a question from alan
here how come the humidity
inside a cloud is a hundred percent and
right next to it it's practically zero
oh that's an interesting question okay
so
uh here's the basic story
one of the things that happens in
materials is a thing that's called phase
transitions so
one knows that materials can exist as
solids
as liquids as gases and
if you take some water for example and
you heat it up
then exactly if if you're at normal
you know normally if you're just doing
this to at um
in your normal sea level place
so to speak um you heat up water
and at 100 degrees centigrade the water
if you if you make the temperature
of the water when it's below 100 degrees
centigrade
it's liquid water when it's above 100
degrees centigrade it's steam it's a gas
uh or what is it 240 degrees fahrenheit
is that right
um but um there's a definite temperature
where the water transitions from being a
liquid
to being a gas that's called a phase
transition it's a very interesting
phenomenon that there's this kind of
sudden transition it's like many things
in the world when you change something
like you gradually change temperature
you might think
the water would gradually go from being
a liquid to a gas
but as soon as the water is at 100
degrees centigrade
it basically becomes a gas a little bit
of a footnote there
you can actually superheat water and you
can
keep it uh not becoming a gas if the
water doesn't have
any place where it can start to become a
gas if it doesn't stop making those
bubbles and things if you can
prevent it from ever forming a bubble
you can actually
superheat it to the point where it's
above 100 degrees centigrade and it
hasn't yet nucleated there's been no
place where it started to form a gas but
in a first approximation
uh water below 100 degrees centigrade
it's liquid water above 100 degrees
centigrade it's a gas
okay so that's what happens uh normally
if you for example if you live in denver
which is
one mile above sea level the atmospheric
pressure is lower
and the temperature at which um
water boils gets lower
as the atmospheric pressure gets lower
and so that
that means that the um uh i'm sorry it
gets
gets higher
which way round does it go oh my gosh
no i think it gets it gets higher as the
as the pressure gets lower
as the air pressure gets lower the
temperature
let me think about this for a second um
well let me keep on with the explanation
and that will come out as we try to
explain more
so so what happens is
all right what what causes the water to
boil
why am i talking about this the reason
i'm talking about this is because a
cloud
is a giant area of steam and when it
rains
that's happening because that steam is
condensing into liquid water
and falling out of the cloud um
okay so the um uh
the thing that um um
so what happens when when so so normally
when water is uh a solid in form of ice
for example
what's happening is that the the
molecules of water
are um okay i have to explain first of
all
what is temperature so temperature is
the average
energy the average kinetic energy the
average speed actually
of molecules in the material so as you
as you heat something up
to increase its temperature what you're
doing is you're increasing the average
speed
the average kinetic energy of all the
molecules in the material
so as things get hotter molecules are
running around more quickly
as things cool down the molecules are
running around less quickly
and the molecules in something like a
solid
there are forces that bind the molecules
together there are forces that attract
the molecules that's why the thing
becomes a solid
those forces um when when the molecules
aren't when it isn't heated up and the
molecules don't have high velocities and
they're bouncing around
those forces that make that attract
molecules together they win
and the the molecules just get stuck
together in a solid
as you heat the the material up the
the molecules start running around
faster and faster and eventually
their kinetic energy their the speed
that they're running at
is such that they can break out of these
forces that attract the molecules
together
and so the first thing that happens is
they break out of kind of the rigid
arrangement of molecules
that you get in a solid and they start
running around a bit
and that makes a liquid and then as you
heat it up more
they start running around and you get um
and they
they they form a gas where the molecules
are running around very quickly and
where there aren't really
forces of attraction between molecules
it's it's only the molecules only
interact by basically uh uh running into
each other
um and they're not they're not sort of
they're not held together by forces
at least no first approximation okay
so the next big question is why does
the uh boiling point why does the
temperature
at which the molecules can break away
from these forces
associated with um uh um
uh with the liquid that that that term
that make them form a liquid
what what as you change the pressure
as you change the the um uh how does
that
affect the um um
the way that works okay this requires me
to think a little bit
in real time um
the uh let's see
um
i am trying to think because i remember
the dependence
of um of uh a boiling point
on pressure um but i can't remember what
which way around it goes so let's let's
have a little think about that
um i also remember that there are these
things called pressure cookers
and i think the idea of a pressure
cooker is you increase the pressure
and you decrease the boiling point so
that from knowing that piece of
technology
i'm pretty sure as you increase the
pressure you decrease the boiling
point um but let's think if we can think
this through
um so as
the pressure decreases so so
within the liquid it doesn't really
matter what the what the
pressure outside is because the liquid
is being held together by its own
uh forces of molecular attraction uh
when you're
outside the when you're in the gas
the question is um what is the
uh how does the ability to turn into a
gas
how is that affected oh yes i see how
this works
um right by uh by what the pressure of
the gas
and the pressure what is the pressure of
the gas
the pressure of the gas depends on
the basically the number of again this
is this is a little complicated
okay there's a whole area of physics
called kinetic theory
and kinetic theory gives you uh
various results like for example as a
result that the
pressure is equal to if i remember
one third times the number density
times c squared times the average
velocity
um if i remember correctly no it's it
has a
it involves the mass of the molecules as
well one-third
nmc square bar i think um
the uh uh okay i'm getting i'm getting
too complicated here
let's let's let's just say that
the um uh the main bottom line is
the um the temperature at which
water becomes a gas
will vary with pressure and um
so so why is that relevant
um it's relevant because the um
uh when as as you go up in the
atmosphere
the pressure progressively goes down but
exactly how the pressure goes down
depends on
uh depends on air currents and all kinds
of other things
this this is getting very complicated
i'm sorry the i mean
the basic bottom line is the the
outlines of clouds
are determined by uh the
pressure temperature and humidity of the
air
and there is a particular uh
value there's a sort of critical value
it's kind of a phase transition type
thing where you get um uh
where you get the formation of uh
we get a cloud and again it's a little
complicated because it involves this
thing called the critical point
which is the uh
okay so when you have like a liquid
and a solid they're very distinct kinds
of things you can really tell whether
something is a liquid or a solid at
least most of the time
a solid you kind of bash on it and it
moves
a liquid you kind of put your hand in it
and you can move your hand through the
liquid
so most of the time solids and liquids
are really distinct
now it's a little tricky because things
like glasses
glass that you find in a window for
example that's kind of a combination
solid liquid thing
and in fact over the course of hundreds
of years the glass and a window will
gradually flow like a liquid
and get sort of thicker at the bottom
because of gravity but so
but in a first approximation solids and
liquids are really distinct kinds of
things
so you might say well liquids and gases
are similarly distinct kinds of things
but actually they're not
there's there's a this notion of um
oh gosh little complicated as you as you
uh you can make it so the liquid is it's
very
uh it's it's a liquid which is very low
density and it's a gas that's fairly
high density
and in both a liquid and a gas the
molecules are just sort of running
around
in a liquid they're kind of constrained
in where they can go by these forces
between
them in a gas they're kind of not
constrained where they can go
but there's sort of a a so-called
critical point which is a sort of
crossover
where if you're looking at something at
the critical point you kind of look at
it it's kind of this
this uh thing that looks a bit like a
cloud and there's good reason for that
but you kind of can't quite tell if it's
a liquid or a gas
it's kind of a it's kind of like a gas
except you can't see through it
um it's it's it's opaque it's it's full
of little tiny
but you can also think of it a little
bit like a liquid because it's got but
it has little tiny droplets of liquid in
it and and right at that critical point
uh one of the characteristic features is
that it has
droplets of all sizes or roughly all
sizes
from the very very tiny to the much
bigger and it's
it's it's some that's a an important
feature
of of clouds and what's what's make what
makes them white
and things like that is the presence of
these essentially
droplets of of different sizes i'm
getting way too complicated on this and
i'm not i'm not doing a good job here
i'll say one more thing about about
clouds and
and their formation um there are
uh okay so so one of the issues in the
earth's atmosphere
is that there you know there's wind that
everybody knows about at the surface of
the
of the earth where wind is blowing in
one direction blowing in another
direction if you go up uh in the
atmosphere
you'll find that there are updrafts and
downdrafts there are places where
the the air is circulating vertically
and for example if you fly gliders
you're always trying to find
thermals which are places where the hot
air is rising
um and because hot air is less dense
than cold air so it floats on top of the
cold air
so the hot air will rise and if you have
a glider there it'll put the hot air
rising will push your glider up
same with eagles and things we'll we'll
go around looking for thermals where
they just have to hang out and spread
their wings and just the updraft of the
air
because it's because the hot air is
rising will will
um uh will make them uh go go up um but
but any case so
so in the atmosphere there are there are
continually these
those are called convection cells where
there's a place where the air is going
up because it's hot
and there's another place where the air
is coming down because it's cold
and those convection cells are important
for forming
uh for forming the conditions where you
get clouds so for example cumulus clouds
have convection cells um uh below them
and around them
that that uh cause the clouds to form
where they form
i mean one of the things that's another
question you might ask is okay
a cloud is a bunch of water vapor um
what makes it
turn into rain and roughly what happens
is
that when the pressure and temperature
uh gets to a certain value the droplets
in the cloud will start getting bigger
they'll start
they'll start um it'll be sort of closer
to being liquid
and more water vapor will be uh
accreting onto the surface of these
droplets
and then there's a critical size i think
it's 18
microns if i remember correctly where
where um
the um these drops will get big enough
that they start falling under gravity to
the point
and and they end up as they fall
they'll kind of run into each other and
these drops will
will um collide and they'll merge and
then they'll get big enough
that it's no longer the case that um
they can be
uh kept aloft in the in the air
just by by uh by by air currents
pushing them up they get too heavy and
they'll fall
uh through the air and then they fall
out as rain and that's that's kind of
how
how rain arises in clouds okay that was
a bit of a messy answer so sorry about
that
um uh
let's see we've got a lot of questions
here oh my gosh so many questions
so many interesting questions um
well there's a question here from
mahmoud
what is your opinion leonard euler or
albert einstein
well i suppose that that's compare and
contrast these two individuals
so um uh i've studied a lot of
historical biography i have not studied
those two people
as much as i might have done but to give
you some sketch
leonard euler was a mathematician lived
in the 1700s
albert einstein was a physicist who
lived in the first half of the 20th
century
around 1870 to about 1950.
so very uh
different kinds of characters leonard
euler was really the person
who um uh took
calculus and things like calculus in
mathematics
and kind of made them streamlined
i mean people had talked about calculus
before euler
but uh euler really made it into an
efficient tool
and lots of the exercises that people do
in calculus books today
were things that euler originally worked
out and an oiler invented some other
important things so he he um
a lot of a lot of the mathematics that
we use today
uh euler really systematized so for
example pi
uh pi the the ratio of the circumference
to the diameter of a circle
3.14159 etc um
euler didn't invent pi pi was actually
known
in antiquity and even the name pie
came from a man called jones um who
lived in england but leonardo
was the person who sort of popularized
the use of pi
and also i the square root of minus one
was invented by a chap called cardano
um in the 1500s but euler again
sort of streamlined the use of complex
numbers and famously
uh euler was i think responsible for the
formula
uh e to the power e the exponential
constant to the power
i times pi uh plus one
equals zero very famous uh uh
fact in mathematics that relates uh
different mathematical quantities
some people think that the e for the
exponential constant for exponentials
2.71828
that number that that e is named after
euler it isn't
um there's uh that e is named for
exponentials but euler was much involved
in
in talking about about e um he also
invented
um he invented graph theory
he was the first person to really talk
seriously about um
about gra abstract graphs just networks
where you say there are these points and
you connect them together in a certain
way
you just talk about these connectivity
the connectivity of points
actually his reason for doing that he
lived in a city called koningsberg
that is now in poland i think
it was in germany for a while i think
it's now in poland
um but in konigsberg they um
uh um might be wrong it might be in
germany
um but in any case the the um uh
in konigsberg there was uh a river
and there was an island in the middle of
the river and there were these bridges
between the mainland and the island and
there was a pattern
of uh five or six bridges and so people
on a on sunday afternoons in konigsberg
uh they would go out and they would try
and um you know take a stroll
around the island and the bridges and so
on and there was a question
could you go over the bridges of
koningsberg in such a way that you go
over every bridge just once but
you don't uh you never retrace your
steps you never go over the same bridge
more than once
and so uh that turns out to be a problem
in graph theory
and euler solved that problem and i
think
showed in the case of the bridges of
koningsberg you couldn't do that you
couldn't just go over every bridge once
and only once
and that that kind of way of going
through a graph because you can think
about the different
the different uh paths you can take over
this bridge over that bridge et cetera
et cetera et cetera is
being these different uh paths going
through this graph of different
connections
um and that uh the thing you invented
there is called an eulerian circuit
um of whether you can whether you can go
around a graph
or not and there's just a simple
criterion in terms of the number of
number of edges that meet at a
particular point on the graph
um to determine whether you can make an
eulerian circuit or whether you can
stroll over the bridges of koningsberg
on a sunday afternoon or not
but so soyula was responsible for
inventing all sorts of things that sort
of streamline
mathematics um a lot of stuff with
differential equations
i have a copy of euler's collected works
they are
they're big they're they're they're
they're a whole shelf
um uh his of the things he wrote in his
life he wrote a lot a lot of stuff
so that was kind of euler's story
einstein was a very different kind of
character
he was a physicist and he wrote
comparatively little
um but he wrote some very high impact
things he he basically
oh he invented the idea of photons
basically
uh he figured out relativity um he
figured out
uh general relativity the theory of
gravity
he figured out a bunch of early things
in quantum mechanics
um he always used to say that
um you know mathematics was a struggle
for him which was kind of funny because
a lot of the physics that he did used
advanced mathematics
of its time but he was sort of lucky
because he didn't really have to invent
that mathematics that mathematics
had all been invented particularly the
mathematics of differential geometry
which he used in his theory of gravity
had all been invented like 20 years or
so before
he had to use it um so he was he didn't
he had to understand enough of the
mathematics to use it in his physics
um but he didn't um uh he didn't have to
um
uh have to have to do um
um uh have to invent the mathematics so
to speak
so you know very different kinds of of
of scientists mathematicians euler
wrote a huge amount of stuff was very
involved in systematizing and
streamlining and organizing
uh how you should compute things
einstein
had a a small number of very good
insights about how things should work
he didn't really get involved in
carefully calculating what would happen
uh other people followed up on his
theories and did that
he was much more of a a have the great
idea type
thing and uh write it down his papers
were usually quite short
um and uh and sort of take it from there
so to speak
so but very different kinds of people
very very different um kinds of
contributions to the history of science
and mathematics
um and hard to compare as these things
usually are
um
let's see
oh boy
um
so many questions here it's a lot of
detailed
questions um
well oh there's a weird one here
how important is money in science
there's many different ways to answer
that question
but you know if you look at the progress
of science
there's kind of big science and there's
smaller science
some kinds of areas of science just need
a lot of money to
to to do them for example
any piece of science that involves
launching a spacecraft
guaranteed to need quite a lot of money
uh if you're if your science
is uh you know explore the outer planets
of the solar system
you need a billion dollars to to play so
to speak
if your science is go figure out another
mathematical result
you don't need you know you need the
money to uh
to keep yourself uh you know fed or
whatever
you you don't you don't need you don't
need anything much at all
it's you're just uh sort of uh uh
paying for people's time they're
different kinds of science and the
different advances in science that have
needed different amounts of money
sometimes paradoxically
the more money you put into an area of
science the less quickly it progresses
because you have to set up all these
structures for how are you going to
spend that money in things and it
becomes very difficult to have sort of a
you know a new innovative idea but you
know
there are there are big areas of science
let me mention some of the
the successes of of big science so to
speak
one success is the human genome project
so
uh you know we all all of our cells in
our bodies contain dna
uh all of the sequences of uh
the our dna contains these programs
which in the case of humans have six
billion
base pairs six billion agct
um uh choices and and that
that program specifies basically how to
make a human
and so it's it's very interesting to
know what that program is
because uh for example
knowing that program tells us uh
how what what kinds of proteins and
things what kinds of molecules
get used in different parts of the human
body
what things might be relevant for
medicine and so on
variations in that genome from person to
person
can tell one what causes one person
to have this characteristic or that
characteristic or to be able to get sick
in this way or that way
and so about uh what was it 20
about 20 years ago now there was a big
effort mounted to um to sequence the
human genome to actually find those six
billion base pairs
that corresponded to the human genome
people had sequenced
uh little bacteria viruses
for example the coronavirus has a genome
that is 29 000 base pairs long so it's a
very short genome
much shorter than the six billion base
pairs of humans
the first critter that was was sequenced
was a thing called phi
x 174 if i remember correctly
which is the bacteriophage which is a
virus that
that uh infects bacteria and it has a
very short genome
maybe a thousand base few thousand base
pairs
um and that was comparatively easy to
sequence
but it was clear it was important to
sequence the human genome which was
much bigger than any genome that had
been sequenced before so there's a big
effort mounted
to sequence the human genome it's an
interesting case because
uh the us government paid for an
initiative to sequence the human genome
and some companies paid for an
initiative to sequence the human genome
and actually the companies ended up
doing it first and then there was a big
partnership
between those those groups but um uh
the um uh but it cost a lot of money to
do and it was sort of a big science
project
that has been uh has been quite
important has been sort of a defining
thing
in in in areas of biology it hasn't
quite yet kind of perhaps lived up to
what people might
hope it would eventually achieve i mean
i i for example
got my genome sequenced about 10 years
ago you know
get this disk drive back of here's your
genome
and um you know i can pull it up on my
computer and i can look at any part of
my genome
and see you know how am i is is that
part of my genome exactly the same as
everybody else's genome are not exactly
the same
but it's not clear what the significance
of that is usually anyway that's one
example of a
quotes big science project another
example of a big science project is
particle accelerators
um for example the large hadron collider
at cern
was a collaboration of many countries
including the us
um it cost about 10 billion dollars um
and uh it's it's it's this
uh thing that accelerates protons and
antiprotons
to very high speeds very close to the
speed of light um
and makes them crash into each other um
to find out basically
uh what other particles exist they crash
into each other very high energy they
produce these big
showers of particles and that's where
the higgs boson particle was discovered
for example
um and so that that project
is very interesting for physics doesn't
really have any practical applications
that anybody knows yet
so that's an example of a big science
project that was done
kind of just to try and learn more about
how physics basically works
probably what was discovered at the lhc
is probably
enough clues i would guess given what
we've done
in our recent sort of uh effort in
fundamental physics probably enough
clues
to be able to find the fundamental
theory of physics
there's a big discussion about whether
the world should build a bigger particle
accelerator
and if so what kind of particle
accelerator it should be um
you know should another 10 billion 20
billion whatever
uh dollars be spent on building another
particle accelerator is it worth it
so that's another example of a big
science project just cost a lot of money
another big science project is a
project called ita which is being built
in the south of france
it's an attempt to make a a nuclear
fusion
reactor so you know the sun
is powered by um
uh the fusing of of uh the nuclei of
hydrogen atoms together
which releases a lot of energy um a
nuclear power station is powered by
the breaking apart the fission of
uranium plutonium
some of these heavy elements but you can
get even more energy by fusing together
light elements like hydrogen
and the question is in a hydrogen bomb
that happens explosively
but the question is can you do that in a
controlled way can you make a controlled
nuclear fusion reactor and people have
been trying to do that
for more than 50 years now by by heating
up
uh hydrogen gas to the point where the
uh
the nuclei of the hydrogen are going
fast enough that when they run into each
other they fuse
it's been very difficult to do that uh
there's a big project
as i say i think it's around uh i forget
it's
on the order of ten billion dollars
project um to build
a um uh something which would be an
example
might work in the year 2035 or something
like that an example
of how one might build a fusion reactor
so that's another example of a big
science project
that one is sort of a mixture of well
could be useful if it works
and let's just figure out if it works
type thing
um another big science project then
there are other big science projects
that involve well for example the
ligo gravitational wave detector was a
big science project
which doesn't really have practical
applications uh directly but is
again a basic science project and that
sort of amazingly
the ligo gravitational wave detector is
able to detect
the collision of two black holes pretty
much anywhere in the universe
from the gravitational radiation that's
emitted as a result of that very violent
event
can be detected on earth through through
ligo but so those are examples of some
sort of
places where spend a lot of money on
science you can get a big result
um other places like in mathematics it's
like
you know spending more money well you
can have more people working on things
but that's uh it's a it's a small effect
it's not something where you
are spending you know where you kind of
need um a huge amount of money to to
make something work
um okay somebody is telling me that um
uh um
various people are pointing out the
boiling points increase with pressure
which um uh
oh yes that does make sense see i'm
sorry you you
this is one of these cases where where
um
uh right the the um
it's a little bit difficult to think
that through but yes okay
so sorry about that um
it's uh there's one of these cases where
i should allow myself to just look for a
moment
to kind of feel like i'm doing the uh
the closed book homework project so to
speak
where um i'm not looking anything up um
so
[Music]
um
let's see
oh boy there a couple of questions about
um
okay this is a fairly simple one here
from planumbra
is there a maximum limit on temperature
uh
based on the fact that particles can't
exceed the speed of light
um the definition of temperature
is it is the average kinetic energy
of particles the average energy of a
particle
so in standard kind of high school
physics
the relation between speed of a particle
velocity of a particle
and its energy is the kinetic energy is
a half
mv squared where v is the velocity and m
is the mass
but when you do relativistic mechanics
that the formula is not that it's a half
mv squared divided by
square root of one minus v squared over
c squared where c is the speed of light
and so when in in
relativistic mechanics you put more and
more and more energy into a particle
and it can never go faster than speed of
light and that formula which i said too
quickly
is such that as you put more and more
and more energy into the particle
the particle will um uh
its speed will get closer and closer and
closer to the speed of light but it can
never exceed the speed of light but you
can keep putting energy into it
so since temperature is defined as
the as as proportional to the average
energy of particles it doesn't matter
that there's a maximum speed to the
particles you can keep putting more
energy in
just happens that their speed won't keep
increasing so the basic answer is there
is no upper limit to temperature
on the basis of just putting energy into
particles based on speed
now there are uh potentially upper
limits to temperature
produced by other things for example one
of the things that um
uh well in in in our model for
fundamental physics there is
a very very large upper limit to
temperature
um because of the fact that
uh well it's it's
because of the uh when you have a one
way to think about it is
when you have a particle that has enough
energy
it would correspond to a mass
that will cause that particle to
basically
produce a black hole around it that that
doesn't happen at any temperature we can
you know ever imagine getting to but in
principle if you increase the
temperature high enough
you'll get essentially a mass energy
associated with that particle
that will cause it to uh to make a
singularity in space-time
um that's one reason to have a highest
temperature it used to be the case that
in particle physics people thought in
the 1960s
up until about 1970 that um there might
be a maximum temperature and people
imagined
that as you increase the temperature you
just get more different kinds of
particles
produced and that there were enough
different kinds of particles being
produced
that you would just as you increase the
temperature instead of
the energy going into making kinetic
energy of particles moving around
it would go into the mass energy of
having additional particles
additional types of particles produced
that was a thing called the hagedorn
theory
that theory doesn't seem to turn out to
be correct it was actually
a theory closely associated with the
first version of string theory
um and it was uh it just didn't turn out
to be true
um so so there isn't an upper limit
except for these very very very large
upper limits associated with
gravitational collapse
on on um on temperature so
uh uh
let's see i'm i'm embarrassed about my
uh
lower boiling point thing and maybe we
can go through
uh it's always it's always tricky
because
you know when you think about these
physical effects uh
there are there are lots of different
kinds of things that happen it's like
like one of my favorite examples is if
you fly small airplanes
when you when you so the airplane is is
going along the ground
and and it always says you know when you
when you take off the airplane
you have to push down the right rudder i
think that's the right way around i
haven't done it for a long time
of the plane to stop the plane uh
to stop the plane turning its nose to
the left
okay so the question is why does the
plane turn its nose to the left
and turns out there are you know you
might think oh i know physics
as i did when i tried to learn to fly
small planes and and things
i know physics i can figure out why any
of these things happens
well it turns out there are three
different effects
and it's really hard to know from
physics which of those effects is more
important
one effect is the um see if i can
remember them one effect is that the um
uh the propeller of the plane uh acts
like a gyroscope
it's it's kind of has an angular
momentum and as you
turn that uh the propeller is rotating
in a particular direction like clockwise
or something depending on which way
you look at it um and as you turn the
as as you turn the nose of the plane up
you're you're
turning the angular momentum and that
produces a torque
that goes one way another thing that
happens is
that the um uh that the the
the air coming back from the propeller
makes a kind of spiral
and it hits the vertical stabilizer of
the tail on one side and not the other
and there's a third effect
which has something to do with
the wings of the oh no i know what it is
the third effect is the propeller
um is the propeller is is oriented in a
particular direction because the
propeller is going to be spinning one
way
the blades of the propeller are turned
in a particular fashion because
it's trying to push the air back given
that it's rotating clockwise or whatever
and the as you tip the plane
the um the way that the the propeller is
like a little wing
um attached to the it's kind of like
acting like a little tiny wing
and as you turn the plane the the the
angle of attack the angle at which the
the little
sort of pseudo wing that is the
propeller hits the air changes
and that produces another effect that
goes in one direction or the other
and and i think so so it's one of these
cases where it's like okay you think you
know the physics
you can kind of guess that these effects
i wonder if there's any other effects
and it's hard to know what the answer is
going to be um
and uh so similar
um uh oh okay we've got
this is good people are people are
checking me here okay let me correct
another thing koenigsberg was in prussia
that i knew
um but it's apparently now um uh
kaliningrad in russia um
so it ended up um uh so a bunch of
prussia
ended up in poland but um um
the uh so koningsberg is now in russia
um anyway uh
let's see
it's a question here from suit zero
what's that what's a good way
to gain intellectual confidence um
when there's so many interesting things
how do you choose what to work on or
what to
what to concentrate on yeah well
interesting problems i mean i think
the uh the way to get confidence
about intellectual kinds of things is to
do stuff
and uh and see that it works out don't
pick things to do
you know it's always a challenge to pick
things to do
that are not too easy that you're kind
of bored with doing them
but not so hard that you can't do them
and you know i know in
in my life i've i i tend to find out
that
projects i try to do even when i think
they're going to be kind of easy
it turns out there's you can dig deeper
and there's something not so easy about
them to be found
so sometimes it's a good idea to start
on projects where even though they
seem kind of easy but if you say well if
i do this project you know that
you start doing it and you realize well
actually there's this question you might
ask there's that question you might ask
and you can dig deeper and deeper and
eventually find out that you're doing a
very interesting project
that was kind of harder than you
expected um
but i think the main way to get
confidence is
to do things and and see the results i i
don't think
the and i i think i mean everybody is
different in this respect i
i you know i kind of with my particular
personality
really like doing stuff that people
haven't done before i find that
um uh very sort of satisfying
to think that i'm making a unique
contribution to something by doing
something people hadn't done before
and always a sort of extra extra bonus
points
when a little bit of extra bonus points
it doesn't really matter but but
um when when it's things where people uh
when people say oh that's something that
isn't possible
actually i personally often tend to work
on things which nobody really thought of
doing before
so nobody ever decided whether it was
nobody ever tried it
and said oh that's really too hard um
they just hadn't tried it because they
hadn't thought of doing it
um and uh or maybe they'd vaguely
thought about it but thought maybe it
was too hard but mostly they just hadn't
thought of doing it
so i think the the the main way to get
intellectual confidence
is to do things and to see that you can
do them
um and you know the thing to not be put
off by
is people telling you oh that's
impossible
you know that's too hard etc etc etc
it's just like do what you can do
and um sometimes the thing you pick to
do may be too hard
maybe you know maybe it isn't going to
be possible for a century to do that
but usually even when you pick something
like that there's a
there's a a sort of a a halfway point
that you can get to
that is not is not so hard and is
achievable
um so uh so that's my comment on that
um i think that um uh
you know how to choose what to work on
that's an
interesting issue i mean for me i have
these
big big projects that i'm interested in
and uh
you know for some of them i don't think
that
the things that are that need to exist
in the world
are to the point where those projects
are really doable right now
you know there are projects i've been
interested in for a long time about
nanotechnology about constructing things
out of molecules
but i just don't think that the
technology that exists today
is is quite uh around chemistry and
materials science and so on
is quite to the point where that project
where the parts of that project that i
can contribute to
are really doable i think i would have
to do a lot of kind of building of of
infrastructure to get to the point where
i could actually contribute to the
project
so you know first question is is is is
what's needed to do the project
something that exists in the world
something you have access to
or is it something you know it's like if
you have a project and oh by the way it
needs
launching something on a spacecraft and
you don't have access to a way to get
something launched on a spacecraft
then it's probably not the right project
to do um
and uh uh so you know that that's always
a
a constraining feature um i would say
that uh
for me about half the projects i've ever
done
are projects that i've been kind of
saving up for a decade
two decades three decades whatever their
projects i've thought about for a long
time
and half the projects are projects where
i just got the idea
that this was now possible given the
things that i know and so on
and i hadn't been planning it for a long
time and both kinds of projects i like
because
on the ones where i've been planning
them for a long time i've often been
accumulating
ideas and notes and so on and so on and
so on for ages and ages
and then finally it's at the point oh i
can do this that's what happened with
this fundamental physics project i've
been
sort of planning that for 30 years and
finally started doing it last fall
but for example projects i've been doing
about blockchain let's say
are projects that i've never thought
about doing um
until uh until very recently
so um
let's see
well there's a question here for
somebody who has um
uh graduated from college with a stem
degree in his interest in graduate
school
and is interested in molecular biology
of biochemistry
um you know i don't know there's a few
generic pieces of advice i mean
you know there are fields that go
through these cycles from
times when sort of there's a
methodological advance
things advance very rapidly in the field
and then
um uh and then things slow down and the
decades go by and the thing is growing
quite slowly
if you can get into a field that is
sort of advancing rapidly um that's a
neat place to be
however some fields get sort of very
oversubscribed
and usually the time to get into fields
is usually
right before they really hit the kind of
incredible
over subscription popularity i mean like
machine learning is like
maybe a little bit over its peak now but
but last
you know a couple of years ago machine
learning was like the hottest thing
imaginable and like everybody wanted to
get into machine learning but if you got
into machine learning
in 2012 when sort of modern machine
learning was just taking off
that was a terrific time to get into
that field so for example
in um uh molecular biology and so on
you know i suppose one of the hot areas
there is gene editing
um and you know i think that the um
one one of the issues in graduate school
okay so graduate school in the
biosciences
um can have some issues because
a lot of the work that's done most of
the work that's done is experimental
work
and a lot of that experimental work
has to have people actually you know
pipetting things and cleaning test tubes
and
all those kinds of things there's a lot
of kind of manual work that has to be
done
um and uh you know what can happen is
that people can end up thinking they're
going to graduate school in
science and ending up basically
being essentially lab technicians you
know working on
sort of the details underneath some
experiment somewhere
and and that's that's not such fun and
it it's it's
um uh typically i mean some people some
people really
really like that kind of work but if you
if you want to be sort of inventing
science that's not what you're doing in
that case you're doing sort of careful
work
to uh to to follow through on some some
lab experiment
um so uh
it um so a thing to sort of watch i
would say is you know
what really happens in that lab and you
know are the graduate students the ones
you know doing the pipetting or are the
graduate students involved in actually
doing things which are
uh which are part of really contributing
to the progress of the science
you know i have to say that um uh
uh the future of um
uh of kind of lab experiments i think is
is gonna be very different from the past
actually there's a company i'll give a
shout out to a company called emerald
cloud lab
that um uh we've been working with for
many years and
and has been using our open language
technology a lot
and they've been building an automated
lab
the cloud lab idea is just like the
computer cloud where
there's a big computer and you can
access it remotely
in this case there's a big lab and you
can access it remotely
and you type wolfram language code on
your computer
and it says do this pipetting you know
heat the sample up
run this particular combine these
chemicals in this way run this analysis
and so on
and it's just pieces of software code
and when you press go it tells the
robots that they have
in their automated lab to go and uh
start running your your experiment
um in in in their lab and i think that's
um that kind of automation is going to
be the future
of uh biology and chemistry labs and i
think that's going to change for the
better
the experience of uh of sort of people
in in um
in graduate school in the biosciences
because the things that sort of
can be automated will be automated as
opposed to
them being fed to you know to students
to get done
so i think that's some uh
uh that's that's the story there um
okay well i i should wrap fairly soon
there's a lot of
fairly technical questions about um um
about uh uh physics which i think i
should answer in a different uh
at a different time here um
let's see um
oh there's a question i'll i'll answer
one here a couple more here
um about a certain nicholas bobacci
that's a fun story so
nicholas bobacci was a fictional
mathematician
um and uh originating in the 1930s i
guess
um the
so what happened was that
in mathematics uh
there mathematicians were studying
particular kinds of problems in
particular kinds of ways
and in fact uh leonard euler mentioned
earlier
had pretty much defined a lot of the
kind of
way to think about uh way to
write down notations you know approaches
to lots of kinds of mathematics
a sequence of well-known mathematicians
like gauss and so on
that sort of followed on from that and
there was kind of a tradition about how
mathematics would be done
and that tradition is actually quite
similar to the tradition
that if you learn calculus in um uh
the um um um
you know if you learn calculus in in
high school and so on
um the um
uh the kinds of things that people like
euler did and
and um to some extent even gauss are the
kinds of things you will learn if you do
college mathematics
those are the kinds of things you will
learn okay
well there was an idea that mathematics
should be done in a more abstract way
instead of talking specifically about
numbers and lines and triangles
that maybe one should talk about
mathematics in terms of
uh general kinds of i don't know
morphisms and
uh uh spaces and uh
co-homologies and all kinds of things
that are very generalized versions
of the the more concrete kinds of things
that you might learn about in high
school or college mathematics
there was a group of at that time young
french mathematicians
who really wanted to push this idea of
thinking about mathematics in a more
abstract way
and so they decided they would write
kind of a the definitive textbook of
abstract mathematics
but somehow i think uh as a way to kind
of
um not uh not stick their necks out too
far
and also provide kind of a a certain
i don't know anchor brand for their
mathematics
they decided to author that series of
textbooks
um to to have a a student's
you know a pseudonym for that group that
would be the
author of these textbooks and that the
author they chose was a nicholas bobaki
who had been some minor general i think
in the napoleonic wars
but had nothing to do with these books
and it was just a pseudonym for this
group of mathematicians i knew one of
these mathematicians actually
a person called andre bay um uh
towards the end of his life i i happened
to work at the
at the same place at the institute for
advanced study in princeton
as as he did um and uh
uh so i that's my my one data point of
of people from the bubaki
uh group but um uh the sort of the
tradition of mathematics that
uh the boba key group uh introduced was
a tradition of a much more abstract
mathematics
um and it's sort of a that's for the
pure mathematicians
uh who uh you know are professors of
pure mathematics and so on
it's much more in the bubaki tradition
of mathematics that they tend to operate
there's been a little bit of a trend in
the other direction in recent years
but it's more in that tradition than um
in the tradition of kind of the euler's
and gauss
type tradition from the from the
previous century
um and uh that was sort of the the thing
that was achieved
i'm not sure that everybody really liked
the bobaki approach
it's very abstract one of the kind of
principles of the bobaki approach is
do mathematics in a very pure way
completely
abstracted from any possible
applications
so um and uh for some people that's for
some people that's good it's a
it's a for some people that's not so
good but that was kind of an idea from
from that um
all right maybe one or two more here um
and then i really should should um
should go uh oh there's a question from
joan
here at the end do you think only rich
people can quotes do
science um you know there is
no clear correlation between
uh people um
it's a it's a uh
like so many things in the world there
is
uh it's it's a completely independent
parameter i think
um the uh um
in the past um
um in the 1700s
the early 1800s but particularly 1700
1600s
um about half the people who did science
were independently wealthy and did
science
just as a hobby they weren't paid to do
it
many famous scientists from those days
um were in that category of they did
science because uh because they wanted
to do it
and um they it wasn't what they did to
make a living
other scientists uh isaac newton was one
uh did science for a living they were
professors at universities
um and that's um and they were paid
to to teach newton was i think not a
very good teacher at all
but um uh he quickly got a um
a position where he could do science now
now other people like for example gauss
who i mentioned i think euler also
um they were court mathematicians
so they were basically working for the
government so to speak
um and uh they um uh
so they were uh they would be brought in
like gauss for example
was kind of brought in to help with the
surveying
of uh part of germany actually that very
practical project
led him to invent what's now
differential geometry um the very
important theoretical area was the
result of that sort of practical project
he was given
you know other people so that was sort
of a common path
was to be a court mathematician which in
today's world will be to be a government
you know a government scientist or
whatever working for for the government
um i mean many famous scientists had um
oh all kinds of uh financial problems uh
kepler
johannes kepler a person who invented
kepler's laws did a lot of work in
in polyhedra uh famous scientists um
uh from the late 1500s early 1600s
he was constantly in financial states he
he tried to be an entrepreneur he tried
to be sort of a math entrepreneur
it really didn't work out he had the the
terrible
misfortune that his his mother had been
um
uh was um i don't know how it worked in
those days but she was uh
she was accused of being a witch and so
he spent a lot of time and effort
dealing with the litigation associated
with proving that his mother was not a
witch
which is a very bizarre bizarre thing
but but you know kepler was a person who
was
definitely uh doing doing mathematics
and science and
i happen to know from knowing that
history that he was um
uh he was in all always in
financial issues of people who were
supposed to pay him didn't pay him and
he was always um
you know always had financial trouble i
mean a lot of people different times
like
um you know uh charles babbage
uh worked on early computers in the
1830s and so on
you know happened to have inherited a
lot of money from his his father who was
a banker
uh worked with ada lovelace who happened
to um
uh be um again come from um
in that case the aristocracy in england
uh with lots of land and so on
but but then you know it back in those
days it was about i think it was about
50 50
between people who were employed
to be scientists and people who
did science um as sort of a hobby
um because they made a living some other
way
i would say in modern times the vast
majority of people who do science
vast vast majority do it for a living so
to speak
they do it because they are paid to be
professors
they're paid to to work on government
grants they're paid to work for research
centers they're they're part of
companies pharmaceutical companies
whatever else
the vast majority of people who do
science do it that way
and in fact at this point very few
scientists
surprisingly few scientists do it as a
hobby
um sort of because they um
because they find it fun and they they
don't really do it for a living
i'm probably a rare case of somebody who
at least at this point in my life is an
amateur scientist so to speak i i don't
do science for a living
i do it because i like doing it and you
know
i make my living being a ceo of a tech
company i
i used to make my my living being a
scientist as a professor
um research scientist and so on but uh
for the last
uh 33 years now i made my living as a
ceo of a tech company
now another question is if you look
across the world
at different countries and that to what
extent
science can be done by by different
countries that that's another
interesting question
when does it make sense for the
government of a country to put money
into doing science
um and uh you know if
if if your country has to make a choice
are you spending the money to build
roads are you spending the money to
provide food for people
are you spending the money to uh to run
your military
are you spending your money to do or are
you spending your money to do science
most of the time science in most
countries
isn't high on the priority list now you
know when there's a pandemic
science gets a big push up because
science is important
um although again sort of the
the science that gets done in a pandemic
is very much oriented towards you know
let's find a vaccine let's find
therapies
let's understand how the pandemic
spreads those kinds of things
rather than let's study the basic
science of viruses
although i'm sure that the the existence
of this pandemic will greatly
enhance people's interests and and uh
you know being prepared to spend
government money on
on on doing things but if you look at
the countries around the world
there's a lot of difference in the
amount of money that the government
chooses to spend
on science and that's probably correct
in the sense that there are countries
where
having uh you know what one point is
if you have a country like the us with a
very large economy in the case of the
u.s the largest economy in the world
if there is some new scientific
discovery
that makes it more efficient
to do something that can be done as
part of the economy then if you have the
largest economy you're likely to have
the largest benefit from that
and so you know putting money into
purely basic science
for sort of long-term effects on an
economy makes sense in a case like that
um if you're a small country
where you know your your effort into
funding basic science will be a small
drop
in a big uh um you know ocean
um it makes it's less clear i think some
countries
have had the uh you know as a trade-off
if you're a small country and you put
money into a
particular kind of science and you
become the best in the world
at that particular kind of science that
can be a big win
but the other thing to realize is it's
often useful
in a country to make sure that there are
some people doing basic science
because it gives you uh it keeps
a certain group of people uh who might
be important
you know if a pandemic comes if there's
some other
issue that requires sort of scientific
thinking
uh you know get you know it's really
good to have
those kinds of people around in your
country and if you said well
we're just not going to do any basic
science across all these areas
then the people who really want to do
that kind of basic science who might be
able to leave you the country
will just leave and go somewhere else
and do their basic science uh somewhere
else i mean and
in my own case i grew up in in england
in the uk
um and i was really interested in doing
uh particle physics
and there wasn't really uh
that much particle physics being done in
the uk and so that's why i moved to the
us
um and that um uh that was um you know
that's that's sort of an example of that
dynamic
and um uh you know that that's the way
these things work
all right i better wrap up here and
we've asked um
lots of lots of interesting questions
today i'm i'm um
uh um
um yeah look forward to doing this again
i
i think um uh i really
i enjoy the kinds of questions people
are asking i hope um
uh uh you find these um
uh these sessions interesting
um and um uh
while while the interesting questions
come in and people seem to find it
interesting
i'll um keep doing these live streams um
so for now uh
bye bye and uh hope to see you again
next week okay bye